don't be all on your ass right now
without a sexual at home if you're down
maybe all right all right no no yeah I
mean I'm romantically involved with
someone now hey guys I'm lying right I'm
Dan Savage and Alyssa be crazy we're
gonna watch the gameplay trailer today
for battlefield hardline rescue
multiplayer dan from my understanding
from knowing you for the past three
months you are a fan of this game aren't
you it's better it's good all right cool
battlefield 41 makes me angry what was
that Dad it's like it smoked a lot
interesting I don't play it enough ah
yeah
you're a sore loser in that department
there whoa whoa how does it make you
feel that I said that so I played the
hardline beta trans soon uh actually
this game it's quite fun and I'm really
kind of interested to see what other
game modes there are because it was only
two in the beta so oh cool
yeah all right guys let's watch this
[ __ ] perfect between the LAPD suspected
robbery broken down the LAPD is now
prepared to bring us to do this side
the green light we have to do like the
threat
pretty realistic yeah roll a
all right oh well nice loosely an action
movie
oh [ __ ] sod
oh [ __ ] instead of marijuana factory
yeah everyone in that building just
can't hi sweet oh [ __ ] whoa that looks
like a straight-up like action movie
that I would actually see in the
theaters today I know right mm-hmm
it really does I can't get behind this
this looks pretty awesome I could get
behind it too and do some funny things
what's that got it yeah I don't know
like I like battlefield in comparison
with Call of Duty because it's a little
bit slower and I can handle it a little
better but I mean counter-strike I mean
the thing is is like I like battlefield
I like how it's built and everything but
hardline thus far has just essentially
been battlefield takes ideas from other
games combined it into the battlefield
formula which isn't necessarily a bad
thing it's just kind of what this is so
yeah yeah but if it's like just general
genuinely fun to play you can get
through it
I don't know it just it just looks fun
the banner was fun I might pick it up
I'm still not sold that I need to buy it
right off the bat is basically where I'm
standing right now yeah look it looks
like the version of okay today yeah I'll
wait for the price drop I'll wait for
the price room yeah but I mean the
bottom line is we're still gonna get it
I'm still gonna get yeah oh we're gonna
rain just not get it hey guys are going
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects dad has a gaming channel
you could subscribe to his channel too
alyssa has a channel where she does
crazy stuff well this would be crazy
Alyssa be [ __ ] admitted to a mental
institution kind of crazy
what do you see doing why is he doing
you two is make me feel left out what
what what what is this I'm I'm wiggling
it to subscribe box okay wait wait wait
you guys he has a weird way and it's
funny
illegal amazing shoutouts for the
battery dies Amanda Rainey hi Ryan
could you give me a shout-out I love
your videos keep it up you're right they
would totally gang me wait what was I
talking about what were you I mustn't
I'm talking about something that I
normally talk about so yeah manda rainy
um Amanda as we all know is a female's
name meaning yes the other gay male fan
over here yeah what's going on she's
off-limits
oh yeah well Amanda I don't know how old
you are but even if you were of age I'm
dating someone right now no and I can't
hit on you anymore more overtly more
importantly you can't hit on him anymore
I mean there's yeah no no no you can hit
on him as long as you want so if you
want to hit on him you do that just just
know that there are consequences for
your actions
yeah what but wait no no go talk okay
there are consequences
oh there's cut down here look guys if I
want to [ __ ] him at all [ __ ] but I'm
not going to make everything awkward
Rayden van eck shout-out because of my
name dunk done we're done with you
Raiden Vanek have a good day thanks for
subscribing you know yadda yadda yadda
you're good you're good guy seriously
was named grant right read great and
like I got a thunder dude [ __ ] Dyke I
can kick ass Raiden she remember that
trailer stuff
yeah that was [ __ ] nuts not as good
as not as merciless huh idea what you're
talking it's okay sky top bread talk
brother I don't know I'm not a very bro
I can handle it yeah we're just gonna
replace your ride I don't like you
anymore doesn't matter now I'm dating
someone now lady olive then go on Ryan
can I get a shoutout
sure JD Holloman hey he's got a picture
of Thor the God of Thunder
Thor
that's crazy - gods of thunder you die
be a cool movie if JD Holloman and write
and rate and whatever burst each other
but they look like Raiden okay I'm on
rated and thought if I said yeah you're
just okay I'm just trying to include the
subscribers wrong with that sure yeah
you know sorry JD I just you know give
me much to work off here I'm just trying
to try found a connection and I was
trying to make a good you know humor
about it and make you feel special that
I [ __ ] it up sometimes it can be a
little socially inept about that
Sunderland mmm it's also why we keep him
in a cage when we're done shooting yeah
was like even if you leave the door open
you to stay there cuz it's safe it just
likes the feel he made it his dead you
know guys you understand well alright
cattle cattle boy okay I'm going
cover it your blanket was all right yeah
so who's next fun that's it